what's up pigeon
where are we going we don't talk about
the circle it's a secret what's a secret
exactly I give you Travis
[Applause]
may I oh
are you standing here I don't know if
that's good for me
see you later
what was the deal with the one guy
covered in tattoos hey that's what's
roomie he's a sophomore that guy goes to
college
you're not my type I'm everybody's type
so hot no one's my favorite it's too
late to close it now why are you here
I'm just trying to take you to dinner
I'll pick you up at 8. I must break you
go for it that's who you're fighting
this is your weird little way of
admitting you like me I don't like you
if he manages to lay a hand on me I'll
go without sex for a month like a bet
yeah and if I win
you have to stay with me for a month
you're on
pack your bags pigeon you're coming home
with me
don't cross this line okay Wall of China
wow what's this it's not a pen I'll tell
you that
you embody everything that is wrong with
your gender
we can at least be friends
but with no benefits
there's so much about me he doesn't know
[Music]
and I'm madly in love with you shut up
and just kiss me
[Music]
hey Abby give me a hug hey baby girl
don't greet her like this it's too porny
[Music]